okay
awesome like wow like totally freaked me
out
now we're in before we start our
interview
with the great fortune feamster who was
do you want to finish
wiping off that dandruff or it's not
dandruff what was it it's costume
disease debris
okay you would know if you ever had one
costume
you just when someone realizes they're
on camera and just starts like
doing the weirdest shit there's no one
to tell me all of us
um before we get to the great fortune
feamster who is our guest
today she's effervescent funny
dry she's the best so
smart funny intelligent goofy silly
poised unpoised i feel like it's like it
will be a very soothing interview it's
very just like funny
she's known me for a long time she uh
tells a couple embarrassing stories
about me
and is a goddamn delight everyone's very
embarrassing
let's get let's get through a couple
announcements
so you guys are clear the touch me tour
is on
a lot of people are texting me they're
confused our show's added are we sold
out
let me just let's do this um toys or
puzzles
tours are gonna put them together so if
you wanna show up
do the work i worked so hard and spent
so much money on a website with all
these
dates and people like i don't get it so
let me be super clear
every date is on sale now no codes the
codes and the pre-sale codes all that
shit is confusing
but helium comedy club was sold out but
they added capacity very
exciting so there's still a couple
tickets left july 8
to 11. this is my last like club
tour like doing small venues before the
big theater ever in your life
it's your last time to see me up close
and get the drop right from my mouth
and then you're moving on then i'm going
to reno nevada with the great taylor
tomlinson
y'all have seen her on this show before
we have chemistry
we're obsessed with each other but also
kind of hold up a mirror to each other
and in quarantine we are the doublemint
twins
we decided to uh do shows together so
this is the last
one that we i feel like this is like
offering to drive someone to the airport
like four months later like oh i forgot
about that
i know that every announcement is this
is the last one
this is the last this is the last time
uh taylor tomlinson and i and we're
doing some rand
random casino on the grand sierra resort
july 23rd have a weird weekend
the mirage las vegas august
7th we are doing vegas we are doing
sequins we are doing
glamour full glamour full thing you're
going to see i'm going to put in a bump
it
then shows where we have sold out but we
are adding
shows don't panic clearwater florida
september 11th
the capitol theater we're adding a show
boston massachusetts october
2nd at the wilbur theater guys i will
not make the same mistake i made last
time when i was at the
wilbur theater in boston where i was
talking about the patriots the football
team and i went
so the boston patriots and then you were
attacked boo
i don't i didn't realize that was such a
sore subject i will make that mistake
because i don't know what she's talking
about
ridgefield connecticut uh richville
playhouse we're adding a show on october
9th
atlanta georgia you're sold out but we
are adding a
show november 5th then come get your
peaches down in georgia royal oak
michigan i love you guys we've already
added a second show
so um we're getting close to sold out
there minneapolis we're we sold out and
we are going to play another
um show uh november 20th at the pantages
theater
fantasies and then chicago illinois we
added a show let's add our
add more let's add or done let's get her
done i love you guys any more
announcements
we have we got merch we got the merch
out it's on the website
store.whitneycummings.com
i don't know i'm weak and i'm bobbing
and weaving and waving
we got all kinds of stuff on there that
you need to go see and look at and check
out and buy
and if you wear it to the show then you
know we'll we'll wave at you like like
little waves
yes uh will uh
do a selfie with you i will throw my
back out bend over and take a picture
with you because it really does
warms my heart
last announcement you can leave us a
voicemail eight one eight
five three eight nine nine four zero
tell us your problems tell us your
concerns
talk to us questions questions episode
but all you do
you guys call and just yeah you're
trying to ask me if it's working it's
like is this working is this working
we're just here
like can you guys hear me write your
question down don't be nervous don't be
drunk don't be gross
and then also write it to good for you
fans at gmail.com you can send videos
you can send uh
snippets of audio you can send uh long
beautiful messages from the war
whatever you want to do that's for help
you can also text whitney
um at
all kinds of stuff 818-239-7527 that and
you can like and subscribe this youtube
channel
you can hit the bell notification so you
are updated every time that we upload a
new video
make sure you don't miss any of this
good for you goodness this is a lot of
announcements
if you don't like these announcements go
ahead and do all this stuff to keep
repeating it to you
love you so much too sweet too salty
don't ride elephants
fortune okay oh this is an intro but now
we're leaving
fortune feedster tonight
just the idea that if you come on this
podcast like you have to like you have
to do it
i'm here and everyone says it's like so
sad everyone's always like
no i'm all bitch
it's so funny because it's book it's
like your dream in life that
people know something you've done yeah
but
i like you know when you you've like ice
cream dance i bet is one of them when
you've done something for so long
and that's someone just discovered it
and they're super excited about it
so they see an airport like ice cream
dance and you're like quick
[Music]
but it's also like you know when you've
worked hard to be known for certain
things and then someone will just come
up to me and airport me like
that's the thing it's got to be organic
and people resonate with
it it's very catchy yeah but there is
something deeply shameful about having a
catchphrase like is that my that's the
ticket
that's the ticket is that that like do i
know have a
there's your son john can we talk oh
yeah what
what other comics have had catchphrases
uh like
kevin there's your son that was jeff
foxworthy
what was it there's your son oh yes and
then
was that billion billion not billy
do all white men look alike to you kind
of
wow no the guy without the sleeves larry
the camera
no that's get her done oh get her done
you don't say that after you have sex
with jax
yeah i say get i just got her done uh
and do you know his real name is dan
whitney oh i forgot
is that weird that is it's just it's
definitely different than larry the
cable guy it's just kind of interesting
that that's his last name and paris
hilton's middle name is whitney i'm
learning there's more whitney's than
just me and it sounds like it's a lot
about you
starting to be insulting yeah in case
you haven't already caught on we have
the legend fortune feamster on
the show today oh this is so exciting
i've never done icon legends star
fortune
has 49 different podcasts we can barely
get through
the first five minutes of this one so
can you help us i'm here for you can you
help me start a podcast yeah
you're doing great i mean we're in a
full studio here
there's lights i've uh there's some
very high tech images of your content
your upcoming tour and special we
printed them out i believe we're at
kinko's plus
kinko's kiosk that is uh a lot of ink
right there i'm impressed
we are holding up your integral studio
we have hamstrings on little wheels
powering the lights and
then let me ask you something because it
was real um
we're real friends we are we friends
yeah we are we are friends
i don't get to see you very much though
and especially during the pandemic
i feel like we should probably hang out
at some point you guys know each other
but i saw fortune three days this week
but i've known you since like 2000
eight or nine i feel like we're so much
closer than
we are because we've known each other
for so long and we've gone through so
much together but like
like we'll see each other every like six
months and but that's like a st
but that's like stand up yeah i talk
about that with like angela johnson
she's always on the road
you're always on the road i'm always on
the roads if i saw angel at the airport
like hey what's up like yeah time
headphones
i saw you seven years ago at just for
laughs comedy festival yeah cause when i
started
uh stand up at the comedy store in 2007
and you were one of the few women there
and so any you know i feel like anytime
there was other women
yeah yeah he's like oh my god you're hi
you know yeah it was just kind of like
this weird thing where you know we've
always been around each other so there's
also this thing where comedians take
each other for granted like
yeah i don't think we've hung out during
the day but this might be our first
day you know when you see a snail out of
a shell
you know it's like seeing you know what
it is because a lot of comedians we see
each other all the time but at night in
the club
and then for some weird reason you're
like let's have lunch and you it's like
when you see them it's like running into
your therapist in public we're like
this is like a very weird way to i've
run into comics before on hikes
and it's jarring yeah oh you're being
healthy
oh you're allowed outside or like but
it's also just like we're such vampires
like when we see each other during the
day
it's just such an odd thing but um
but i also don't ask comics to hang out
a lot so i'm glad to see him tomorrow
yeah we've known each other for so long
and i've since with the podcast started
which i want to ask you real quick did
you start a podcast your first one was
sincerely fortune the first one
um was the radio show
no i had the i had like a podcast your
own podcast my own podcast
was my is my first one did you start
that because you felt like you had to or
you wanted to
bo good okay as someone that didn't want
to start a podcast and now
loves it i definitely started it because
i was like i guess like having a podcast
now i was like having a website at this
point like you can't not have one
and i definitely felt like forced to do
it or pressured to do it
and then now i love it right we started
it two and a half years ago
jax does it with me a lot and uh
i tried to do it by myself the very
first episode i lost just like 20
minutes
and i would go yes she's in there
because she did not want to do it and i
i was just like jack
she wouldn't be on the spot because you
felt like
we can talk a lot did you just feel like
oh it's just weird not having like
audience feedback i don't know if i'm
just being a crazy person
or if this is even funny yeah i like the
back and forth i like to have a
conversation
just like sharing my thoughts to me is
so boring
but so why only audio are all your
podcast only audio
yes i do a radio show with tom papa on
siriusxm and we
are doing zoom right and like all the
interviews through zoom right now
because of this remember the time i did
your radio show and you know record
sound
that was uh sorry emily just shot me
with a nerf gun
what happened if i interrupt a guest i
could shot with a nerf gun oh
interesting we didn't finish about your
serious show
i'll bring you let's get serious about
it
i might just get shot with a nerf gun
yeah we all have guns wow okay please
say something so i don't know okay
so we the studio is still closed for a
while so we do the interviews over zoom
and so they show clips and stuff but we
don't put up the full interviews
but with jax and i for our podcast i'm
not gonna lie we're not as organized as
you
so we're oftentimes like ah the podcast
is due
and if we try to also add the video to
that
chaos it would be a lot so who
paired you and tom papa was that your
idea i think they went to tom
and because he was already doing stuff
with siriusxm and they were like would
you be interested in something
and uh you know but that gave them a
couple names
tom papa is one of the funniest people
like
on the planet like he was opening for
jerry seinfeld for so long
that you kind of were like oh that's the
guy that opens for jerry seinfeld and
then i started seeing him do his own
hours and when i went to new york and i
was like
this guy is like unbelievable the way
that his jokes are crafted
are just like mind-blowing well he's a
really incredible writer and so he's
creating
constantly that's the biggest thing with
stand up for me is the writing yeah i'm
always like oh my god
like what am i going to talk about how
do i craft a story
and he's just very prolific i mean he's
like
such a pro but remember the time i did i
remember i was in new york doing a press
tour
um uh don't ask that's my pet bat
sorry girl what is that sorry you're
walking
down yeah
[Laughter]
so for those of you that did not hear
that squeal there is an alarm in my home
my home is being redone and apparently
there's an alarm in the wall no one
knows where it is and they said we'd
have to tear up all the walls to find it
and i said fuck that if i have to have a
loud squeal that sounds like a child in
a basement
definitely something like that in the
walls sounds like someone's being
pulled into a van by the way it's a
young victoria woman
we broke behind a wall grace convinced
me that it was a bat
and i was like oh did you guys know that
bats they make the same screech at the
same time every day
and then they're like everyone's like
this has got to be an alarm i was like
no that's definitely a bat and we're
like trying to find it for days do you
know how bad sleep bloody footprints up
and down the hallway
like you're haunted i know and i've like
convinced myself because if this is an
alarm i'm like okay our only choices are
the battery just dies over time
right or we tear up all the walls and
try to find it oh
yeah i'm with you i think you just being
an adult is a nightmare
i know when you're i you're more of an
adult than me i'm coming to your house
and you're doing all these things and
i'm like i gotta grow up
but here's like i feel like being a
comedian and then you like get a life
and you're like a big girl and you have
to deal with these adult things
and someone's like we need to talk about
the alarm and i'm just like making jokes
about bats i'm like man we need to get a
solution to this
like i have a really bad rat infestation
at the moment
in my garage and they tell me about it
and i'm just like where's that i need a
video because i just i just want to put
on my instagram like man we need to
solve this problem
like where is it you're like content
yeah i'm not talking about some leashes
do they look like they could wear like a
little skirt and like walk on like a
ball yeah
i was like it's like all these people
that i have to do really adult shit
and my brain is just like i'm are you
guys always you're always thinking about
content like
is that where your brain goes i don't
think i think my brain is wired to
always find the silver lining in
something because i think that the
saving
like the the medicine of being a
comedian is anything bad that happens to
you
you can sublimate into a funny story
like anything that
like like instead everything is b-roll
everything is real
yeah that's the idea of just like oh we
shot all that stuff the advertisers said
we couldn't put it in but like oh i can
put that like
everything nothing's a waste of time
gotcha
mistakes bad relationships if you like
spill a bunch of stuff and break
something okay let's video and post it
at least we'll get
well at least we can yeah at least i i
have been seeing you in your rock
a lot i know what is that i don't know
but you've known me for so long fortune
what's hap what happened um because you
i knew i knew i was like fortune's gonna
be like the most famous person on the
planet i just remember i remember it
because i remember we would do chelsea
lately together yeah
and you would just they can't they
chelsea would go like
fortune what do you think and the
audience would already start laughing
because you'd have an expression
and you always like had a warmth to you
it was like that's the key to comedy
someone who's so funny but never feels
mean
right i mean i yeah i don't know what
else to do i just
use this crazy southern accent i say
some people start laughing and i'm like
well i wasn't trying to make a joke at
that point
i have pain you're just laughing at my
voice
this is bullying yeah it's bullying but
it also makes writing a little easier
i think you might have gotten bored in
the pandemic and just started like
taking your shirt off
um that's the only thing i can think i
think what happened was a lot of people
are like whitney's going crazy when he's
going crazy he's like no you guys never
saw me
not doing stand up like i you podcast
you see me three hours
a week now yeah that was never i did
crazy stuff it was just
not recorded last night everyone's like
you're you've been crazy like you dyed
your hair colors i'm like dude i was so
much crazier when i was brunette
it just wasn't on the podcast being
recorded when you finally like had a
minute off of all the
30 jobs you were doing and you were at
home but it's also like
for me when i have comments like i'm
going to act silly and create ridiculous
like otherwise like three hours a week
i refuse to be boring i refuse to let
this be morning
yeah i won't let you guys be boy i if i
get bored i'm like let's take my shirt
like i just am like
hey i swear to god i will take my shirt
the opposite of me if i get
i still don't understand why anyone
would listen for three hours
how like why would you listen to me and
me not taking my shirt off
on an audio platform do you hear me
taking my shirt off is this interesting
no you're like the burt crusher of
taking shirts off
or is spur crusher the whitney coming
soon yeah
um it's so wild were you a writer on
chelsea i can't remember
you're a fully staff writer i remember
the day uh you started working there was
it second season
it was no it was um
the third season maybe yeah it was the
beginning of
2011 and i started as a writer i i
submitted a writing packet
because i tried to get on the round
table and was told
i think by michael that was too boring
or not boring sorry
uh what was it too low energy he said
or i don't know it was michael but
probably michael i would that was too
low energy so
i couldn't get on the round table so i
submitted a writing packet
and then everything you said in the
writers room was funnier than that no i
was pretty shy at first my first year
like i'm a little more shy than people
realize like uh
i was just kind of because it's very
overwhelming like people are screaming
jokes first what else i'll say is that
this is they were they were literally
screaming just reminds me of the first
time we had that writer's room meeting
and i was like
have to talk during this yeah writer's
rooms are brutal it's daunting it's
daunting because you have a bunch of
people
that are you know legitimately i think
well-intentioned have good ideas but you
also were comics we're also
used to being the one person on stage
we're not improv people yeah there's a
difference we're
we're not like let's all work together
like this is my gotta get my joke in and
because also if you
don't get your jokes in then it's like
oh well i might get fired do they even
need me so you're having to like
the worst thing in the world is i
remember when i was in writer's rooms
for the roast where you're all friends
and like comedians like
you know to me very few people
understand what we do we should be the
closest with other comedians yeah
empathize with them
and like you feel this intense bond with
comics and then you go into the writers
rooms all out the fucking window like we
we were friends ten minutes ago but now
you're my fucking enemy no that's
my joke like i just did like us being
friends and then all of a sudden you're
like
yeah enemies in the writers room yeah i
just so i just kind of was like i was
more quiet for a while and i was
starting to get my head like thinking
god they don't need me
like what am i gonna do because i
haven't i could tell jokes but
i would think of it like 30 minutes
after the meeting
it's a little early for jokes guys
i really get my groove around 2 15 when
you're shooting the shot can you guys
work on my schedule
and uh it is because comedians thrive at
night and we have to work at 9am
and everyone's like that was really
trippy too because it was like
uh because people be like oh it's so fun
and crazy there you go it is but it's
also a job like yeah
you if you're late you're in trouble you
have to ask for permission
to like go get lunch you know it was a
very
uh structured place which people were
shocked to hear
yeah um but i eventually i think one of
the producers
uh when i was like i feel like i'm you
know not contributing and
i eventually got better at yelling jokes
like a psychopath
in the writer's room yeah but at first
they were like it's fine you were hired
for your sketches
because they basically started putting
me like in all the schedules because
they actually
i wasn't at the groundlings at the time
tell me about the groundlings because
we're gonna get back to this but the
groundlings is my nightmare
the idea of doing like a character and
rolling around on the floor like i
remember
auditioning just being like this is i
can't this is too embarrassing
yeah but you have to really not care
what people think i
mean it's a lot of people i care
whatever like everybody thinks at all
yeah it's a bunch of adults going like
you know
for the next five minutes to me that's
like a
humiliating someone what is what is i
don't know does that make you better at
improv
like help me understand oh i think you
the the beginning part of it is to help
you
get out of the judging yourself yeah
they purposely
the comedians should judge that we
should judge ourselves that wasn't funny
oh shit
what is this nam i like it
it's a war zone fortune shoots me to get
me to not interrupt you it just hits you
in the face
i
[Laughter]
it's way more of a motive for me if
every time i interrupt she gets hit
that's true so that should be
interrupted the original plan was we
were going to play that game with the
knife
oh god don't do that this is like hunger
games you have to try to save me
so i have a couple questions for you
before we get to our games because
are we done with the growling story oh
sorry we are not that was what was
interrupted
i you know i also find improv and stand
up so weirdly different yeah
like just the audience like you're just
doing stand-up during the daytime people
are like
dude they can see me i'm not gonna lie
i'm not doing it but at nighttime
everyone's like they can't see me i'm
about to laugh nobody see me in this
club
but improv shows those people are dying
to talk
yeah they're like what do you think
burrito like what this is like
they've come with their words yeah
they're like we are part of this show
and stand up you're like what are you
doing they're like
but this is what drives me nuts is
different when you do an improv show
from the audience like i just feel like
the audience tries to be funny too
and when you it's like when i go into
interviews and and journalists ask me a
funny question
they're like you know i'm like don't ask
me a funny question ask me a serious
question
i'll make it funny don't worry right so
i don't like when you're doing improv
and you're like anyone have the thing
from the audience and people be like
bill yeah and you're like just say
something not funny and we'll make it
funny yeah
if the audience is trying to be the star
of the show you're like but with improv
i feel like the audience is on their
side like they want you to do good and
they stand up to like proof it to me
well yeah you think you're so good on
your own you don't need anyone else
what made you walk up there and you're
like i'm sorry well it's so funny
because i spent
six or seven years there it was like my
life it becomes like a big bubble
and uh and now i'll do like guest improv
shows and jack's like just
stick with stand up every time
i watch you do improv shows i fall more
out of love with you jax is like you
don't need to act like a penguin anymore
it turns out we don't care what you
would do in starbucks just the sex
appeal kind of goes down
when you like growl like maybe
yeah because i was single for most of
the time of doing growling so i guess
that maybe that was why
i'd love to invite you on a date wanna
come watch me be a civil war renaissance
wife
wasn't jack's a kindergarten teacher so
she's like this is
too familiar with children yeah and
adult actors in hollywood yeah this is
make-believe yeah you don't want your
wife
you know yeah quacking like a duck but i
think that the kind it's interesting
because you're one of the few people
that
that really can do both and be
commanding on stage uh and it's because
to me it's two different muscles
if you're doing improv with other people
my brain is going like no that's not the
best thing whereas on stage i don't have
to worry about
anyone else i always picture the end of
an improv
show being all the five improvisers
doing the show going off stage and
everyone what the fuck was that
why didn't you fucking do the house
thing like that it's this idea of like
everyone's blaming someone else for why
they weren't funny yeah it's like the
eagles everyone turns into the eagles
did you ever do improv i did i did it a
little bit i went to the
the i'm grateful that i went to the
groundlings and humiliated myself a
couple times when i was 22 because it
made
the comeback episode about the
groundlings that much more enjoyable
valerie cherish in the comeback doing
groundlings is my favorite episode of
television
but like i just i i i was just like i'm
not i don't i'm not getting rugburned
for this
like it was like it was a lot of
crawling around on the ground
and i i just was like and not that doing
stand up in front of a bunch of drunk
people at two in the morning for no
money
at that time was any more glamorous or
dignified
i just was like i i just like
hurt my like a few times i did it in
nashville at the improv club and then
one year
i was voted third best improviser okay
third isn't that a weird thing to give
someone i also can't say anything
who voted i'm the type of bitch i i
don't like anything being on record if i
can think of something better later like
i'm the bitch who will call an ex six
months after we broke up because i
thought of a new retort
to one of our fights for real i like be
like can we rehash that because
like i'm the kind of person where if i
do an improv thing yeah
and then we're like okay and then blah
blah and then joke about the house and
you'll be like you know what here's the
joke
like i will try to you want to control
the
the scenario let's do it you do it i
just figured it out
and everything that's my problem because
then when i do improv my thoughts always
like this would be so much better if we
just went and wrote it down right
yeah how would you react
naturally and i was like i wouldn't be
in this situation yeah yeah yeah um
see you i'd leave do you remember bj
novak remember pj novak used to do stand
up
oh yeah i forgot remember he had a joke
that probably doesn't hold up now but
uh he used to have a joke they were like
one-liners he would go battered women
sounds delicious
and then he had a joke where he went uh
uh i just dropped my girlfriend up
i just dropped my jesus i just dropped
my girlfriend off at the airport
and i'm going to pick her up when she
calms down you know like it would just
be these like mitch had burgundy type
like dan or dimitri martin lead one way
and the other way and he did have
something funny about
like an inside joke about improv he was
like you know i know that the
improv adage is yes and but i like to do
no but
[Laughter]
so i think he did some improv yeah where
everyone got to say no but
that was a very mean thing i just
destroyed the scene every time i'd be
like just change it or just switch the
whole thing to something new
yeah i think improv's not probably not
for you guys
no i'm just gonna but that's kind of
what a podcast is so that's why i was
like oh my god everybody that did improv
is going to have such a better
like have more success doing because i'm
so used to planning planning planning
and then presenting it when it's done
like can i not do a podcast i was too
worried i'd be bad at it well it helped
me
tremendously starting stand up because
you don't have a lot of material
so i started i i started having a
headline
pretty quick and i didn't have that time
of getting to open for something but i
didn't see that chelsea lately tour
uh yeah we've been comedians at chelsea
lately
but i i started stand up in 2007 i did
last comic in 2010
and that's when i started touring i mean
that's not much time last comic standing
who are the judges
uh it was greg geraldo
natasha legero and uh and andy kindler
oh
wow yeah so i had only been two and a
half years in the stand up so i'm
touring now and i don't have an
act so i started but i talked real slow
so i could stretch out five minutes but
i started
doing tons of cra using improv to
talk with the audience and ask questions
and i was weaving it into
the act and it was becoming like a fun
challenge for myself to see how i could
use the improv to incorporate it into
the act and
it saved me because i didn't have the
material yeah
it teaches you to trust yourself i also
think that everyone
should do stand-up at least once or
improv at least once
even if you're like going to be you know
a teacher if you're whatever you're
going to do
because it really is one of those things
where you find out so much about
yourself
and about how energy works right if you
go up and down yourself everyone will
doubt you
if you like which is helpful for anyone
in any kind of job marketing if you ever
have to talk in front of people like
you just learned like 10 years of human
nature lessons
if you just do one stand-up set yeah and
go oh if i'm scared they're going to be
scared if i
don't have confidence if my body
language is this and i'm this
you just learn so much yeah that's what
i'm going to do i'm going to start a
comedy school for people that want to
just try it once
to get the psychological benefit there
again well one of the biggest fears is
uh
what death and public speaking and so i
think that why don't you have comedies
both
uh i do have that fear when i did uh i
did theater in college and wanted to
throw up every time i went on stage
honestly improv got that under control
it helped that's right because improv
for me makes me because i'm like i know
i can fucking go out
yes but i don't know fucking have you
been i don't know what your workout that
guy's like are you going to ruin this
you're fucking me
that's what i don't like about it i
trust me but i don't trust all these
other motherfuckers are going to go out
there
you need to be solo though i'm the
person when i'm doing improv i'll like
try to beam them
yeah what i want them to say next i'm
like and then that's why we're gonna go
down to the lake
you're like uh mark i think why aren't
you thinking
mark are you thinking are you thinking
what i'm thinking
yes you have to say yes yes okay well
what we're going to do is we're going to
say are you thinking what i'm thinking
what are you thinking i'm
thinking we should probably go jump in
the water so we're going to take our
shirts off
correctly people know what he meant what
you meant was what i think you
i want to know what's going to go well
audience suggestion they're like church
you're like
starbucks
of course perfect thank you
well i'm glad you filmed stand-up man
i did love touring on that yeah
comedians of chelsea lately tour it was
it was really fun it was me i'm so
curious like i don't mean this to start
like
but i'm so curious who still hangs out
like i'll like i'm following sarah colon
and i'll see her with franjola and i'm
like oh my god like
like i feel like i never get to see
anybody but it's so cool to see people
still
hanging out from that show yeah yeah for
sure brandon was with me
in um whatever some show in in
san francisco it was so fun yeah
it was like oh yeah made me feel like we
were like 28 again well it's fun to be
on tour with
other comics because a lot of times
we're doing it solo but a lot of people
a lot of of them still hang out and i
saw people
i saw frangiola and kelowna and jen
kirkman a couple weeks ago
i did juicy scoop yeah you did heather
mcdonald oh my god i love her
my favorite thing about heather mcdonald
is she is i have so much to learn from
she is so
like brave and we also
call it shameless but in a good way i
wish i had more of it where she will
just ask you a question that is so
like she's gonna get that she gets a
juicy scoop and as she should and this
is what i admire about her like even
when we were in the chelsea lately
writer's room
i would like come in a day that i was on
the panel hey whitney are you dating
uh chris evans because i saw some like
she will ask
the question do you lie about your age
i'm like heather
like like shit i'm like she's like but
that's why her podcast is so popular did
you have a nose job because
this photo it looks like you did so like
she will ask the question
okay she's the original troll she does
not give a
fuck but it's coming from like an
innocent place right you can say no
she's genuinely curious she will ever
the things that everyone's wondering she
will just fucking say so she was doing
juicy scoop before the podcast so juicy
scoop how about this so i go on juicy
scoop and
this was probably when my special came
out this was ages ago when she had it in
like some building in hollywood and i go
in and
and she's just always heather like i i
what you see
she's got the heels on the daytime she's
got the jeans
and the top with the halter top with the
bra during the day
i'm just like you are always heather
mcdonald that's right you know i'm
saying like i am
like slob off cam and then i'm here and
then you know
she is always on the red carpet she is
always presenting the news yeah
she shows up like her special she has
chandeliers she's in heels she's the
hair is perfectly
curled yeah and all the rest of us are
showing up like slobs and buns like she
will not
um not be like heather mcdonald yeah and
um
and she uh uh okay so i went on her
podcast she asked me all these crazy
questions i'm like you know i can't
answer that you know i can't answer that
like just sort of like
but i'm so impressed that you fucking
asked it
that now i want to answer it because i'm
so happy for you right you know
and um and then i remember because and
heather
you will you cannot get mad at me for
this because you know this is true when
a really big public story came out when
the crystalia thing came out
she was talking about a lot on her show
oh yeah which is totally fine
you know everyone should do what they do
but she lives down the street from me
she lives like oh we're like
half a month so i would have never been
to her house i was biking
at the time like my rage away and i
would bike every night back and for the
upper street
and i would see her and i'd see her be
like okay and i was like
yesterday she's not doing well i was
like bye good to see you like she was
ready for the scoop
everything she is trying to get that
scoop girl dude every time
i went up to my corner what time it was
she was like walking up and down the
street waiting
i think you owe her a bike ride because
yeah so she could say when yesterday
she's not doing well she wouldn't answer
my questions
uh you know like why she are like the
sports bra of course matches the pace
she
stays true to who she is by the way
she's a full makeup honor
exercise well i think she was just like
okay let me just wait for it
because it was literally during the shit
storm of that whole thing yeah
and i don't think anyone had made
statements yet it was all coming out and
it's like she just wanted to know like
did you know like she was just
she was gonna be the person that asked
yeah the question no one had the
audacity to ask and the fact that she
was my neighbor was so
funny well the the visual is a real
treat for all of us
so thank you so much
but yeah so she does live around the
corner yeah and i remember we all had
nicknames remember she was long boobs
yeah did you have a nickname i never had
a nickname i think i came i think i came
onto the show after chelsea stopped
naming people she was just like couldn't
remember our first name
any nicknames were just she didn't know
a girl over there but i was yours did
you have one
i don't know but i was thinking about it
but i think for a long time she called
me
we all had nicknames i did it did you
have one no no
[Laughter]
anyways
whenever i came into that show i was it
was like all the cool kids and then you
come in you're like the new kid
and everyone's got all these inside
jokes and you guys are having the best
time but i was never in like the writers
people were all i remember in the
writers room people were always very
impressed with you because
they will have had uh you would have
just done one of those tours
and they would come in and be like well
we were doing a show
and in between comics whitney was like
working on a script
in the corner and i remember chelsea
being so impressed by that
they were like man she's a hard worker
yeah because when i was on the road
doing comedians of chelsea lately
everyone would go out afterwards and i
would and during the day and i would be
writing scripts yeah
a lot of which went on to be cancelled
well at least he's really glad i sat out
all those fun nights on the town with
comedians to write shows that got
cancelled
i hate going down memory lane it's a
haunted house of elaine
isn't it but then we're all very
impressed with your work ethic
that's um that's really nice and i'm i'm
usually half
you know i love compliments that are
kind of like a little bit um
backhanded but not intended to be like
when you come off stage and someone's
like
you're a good writer yeah like a lot of
people say to me like you have a great
work ethic but they i'm like
funny or when they do really good and
they're like a great audience right
but we weren't talking about the
performance yes no i know but
that's just reminding me like do you
ever get a compliment that you don't
feel like it's actually a compliment oh
well all the time
i didn't say anything bad you heard me
right now people say to me they're like
i just i'm so impressed by you i think
it's so cool that you don't care
like at all what people think what you
look like and i'm like
i do care i do care yeah mine's usually
like oh you're not
as big in person you're like okay when
someone said
you're crazy your legs are like crazy
like
mine yeah they're very muscular yeah
yeah i
i i'm an athlete i know it's hard to
believe
but i grew up playing sports my whole
life and i just have this weird athlete
i played college tennis college soccer
and i've my even my tennis coach in
college would be like i don't understand
how your body moves
away it does another backhanded
compliment
and um but yeah i just
my i have this weirdly the chubby
body and also very athletic body in
certain places
i feel seen remember that time benton
this was the first time i was learning
about it benton one time we had to take
a mailbox down or something you know
mailboxes are like
in like concrete underneath the dirt
yeah
benton walked up to it there's like a
handyman trying to get it off and benton
just walked up to it and started kicking
it
without his body even moving like these
crazy kicks and i was like what the fuck
like it was like i've never seen
anything like it yeah the super cartoon
crossfit guy was like trying to pull it
out and he was just thinking
like like a fucking like flamingo but
forward i kicked it back your whole body
did not move and i was like what the
fuck and he was like
by the way the thing was this big the
what do you call it the stem
the holder the the the pole the part
that holds the mailbox
yes it was a square and his foot kept
hitting the square exactly i was like
there's
no he was like i was like a black belt
in what was the karate karate
monorail really amazing
looks like they're in cartoon shape
could figure it out last night at that
show we were on yeah
multiple people touched me and they were
like are you security because you were
in all black and i was like
no i have a that's an illusion for my
brother no i'm insecure i'm
insecurity i'm depressed
insecurity i'm in security
insecurity and so you guys did a show
together last night how were the classes
wednesday
yeah we had two show we were on two
shows later this year
it was pretty great we had never met in
person that's wild yeah and then three
times this week
let me ask you uh uh and then i want to
get to our silly silly ha ha time
uh do you feel like there's anything as
you're going out again that's like
do you have any bets that you're like i
don't feel like i should do it like
uh it's like any material on stage oh
i mean like any bits i do socially with
my friends
are there any classic dinner bits that
you're retiring
they all are the other weird norms
put my spoon on the nose anymore
friend dinners do you not do your silly
faces on dinner anymore
you do social how many bits are you
doing socially i have a lot of party
bits
oh so many parties a card in the card
i have to be honest i have been looking
through old pictures in my computer
every picture of you and i together to
be fair i'm writing you as a horse
or you're writing me as well sounds
about right in the hallway we're
grabbing each other in some sort of way
prom pictures
like every like year or like six months
in my photos there's a picture of me and
you in the hallway doing something so
childish i'm probably grabbing you to be
in front of me
i was being a horse and you were riding
on me and you were riding as a horse
and then we're complaining about men
being toxic oh oh
you know me those men there's literally
girl on girl toxicity in every photo i
have
i'm like jessie making her bitch let me
take your shirt off like it's like
you i always think about you because uh
around thanksgiving because we do you
remember that time we had
thanksgiving at chelsea's and wait wait
wait yes
i sat beside jennifer aniston and you
were on the other side of me
yes and oh my god i was like geeking out
hardcore
jennifer aniston's like i remember this
yeah
jennifer anderson's like i made this
salad i'm like i love salad
is my this is the best style i've ever
had in my life calm down
much i like jeff and so beside you and
you just like
she was like and then and then like
jennifer anderson drops a fork and
you're like
no one told your life
yoga i was out of control that is so
funny i mean it was the greatest
thanksgiving of my life
truly but how did it but then you worked
with her later on
yeah mother and she was so lovely and
she's the best she came
like she's like fortune i haven't seen
you since thanksgiving i like crying
oh my gosh i was telling fortune my mom
watches at the end of office christmas
party there's like just like a blooper
reel of fortune just going over
different like
things she would say like as a lie like
in the middle of the night i was like
have you seen the end of office
christmas party and i was like yeah i
watched the whole movie she's like the
credits
have you seen what happens during the
credits that's where the movie really
pops up
she smushes it over and over i'm like
you can just google it on youtube or
something you know what i really miss
i really miss remember on sitcoms when
they would do outtakes at the end
mad about you would do it i think cosby
show would do it martin would do it
there would be a blooper reel i love
outtakes i know people stop doing that
oh
because they want they don't want to
show you the smoke and mirrors but
also nothing funny happens accidentally
anymore because everyone hates each
other so much the bob is so toxic
there's no funny outtakes everyone says
i'm fucking leaving i'll be in my
trailer i said i wouldn't be in a scene
with her like those are all the bloopers
now
we now take a break during ads every now
and then i'm gonna be fully doing makeup
during the ad if you have a problem with
it
you're a sponsor i agree but what better
way
to talk about better help than um
have someone who's simultaneously doing
their makeup while on camera someone
that clearly
needs better help but you know what i do
know about
being direct i have dealt with that in
therapy
so emily you're in charge of this
sponsor content what are we doing
well i wrote the script last night okay
the script was what we were gonna do but
pivot
okay what was the script we're doing but
the script but i'm letting them know
we're now reading scripts that are
written by our talented
team so that we're not just reading off
a piece of paper they're going to be
like this is talented
so you wrote this in my voice benton did
i hear you say that emily laughed out
loud to herself while writing
oh emily laughed outside the entire time
she was writing
it's not like she left here and there it
was just from the minute she started
typing until she was done she was
laughing and when i said what are you
laughing at she went
my work and then would hysterically
laugh
fall into the floor and then went i
don't need anyone and kept laughing
you know what so this better be the
funniest thing you've ever heard
it's good you don't need anyone because
i have a feeling you're not going to be
fighting anyone off with a stick either
so it's a good place to be um
action action we now take a break from
talking to the hilarious fortune
feamster to talk about mental health
and nobody needs more help in that
department than our very own emily
emily didn't you recently try to talk to
benton about some things going on in
your life
yes and that's when i knew i needed
better help not
benton helped i love that we wrote these
in your voice and then you immediately
changed your voice
here's the video something's interfering
with my happiness and preventing me from
reaching my goals
[Music]
is it you i was dating this guy and
things are going really well but i just
found that he moved and didn't tell me
oh he's obsessed with him he's moving
away
because he wants to be closer to you
emotionally that
sounds wrong
fucking dad again
i feel like you're not talking to me
like a licensed
therapist that's been matched to assess
my individual needs oh license i know
you personally
and i know that what you're struggling
with is intimacy issues
because uh you know you got bangs at one
time coffee is really good
i really wanted to talk to you three
days ago it would have been better if i
had been matched with you
within 48 hours are you describing
tinder
is your mom still an alcoholic
[Music]
do you have a broad range of expertise
yeah i know about basketweed oh
it's just interesting that you want me
to be on your time we've had to
reschedule this
four times to have this coffee i know
because
traffic and getting here and it would
just be
you don't have a car it would be so much
nicer to just talk to the comfort of my
own home
get me to be your roommate do you have
any other advice for me
yeah it sounds like you need better help
better help
they give you real advice from a real
licensed professional therapist
not your friends you can log into your
account
anytime and services are available
worldwide
don't go to horrible friends reverse
advice call better help
coffee is really good we're gonna call
better help uh we're also going to call
um
circuit city for some microphones right
so you can hear
these hilarious sketches moving forward
we're off script again we're also
going to need to uh add some filters
over uh
our loops well this i'm not even says
wow
this is so in my voice that it's just
rolling off my tongue
wow better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
and i have a
feeling they would not condone what we
just witnessed on this podcast oh they
have an
audio department uh they're also more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling
how much did benton charge you em her
what her firstborn child how much did
benton charge you
and you're not going to answer i'm asked
that to benton well it's okay
he interrupts me how much dependence
charge you jump it well you have to do
stage direction
i charge her a child no read the whole
line her first born child
no wait that was when she couldn't guess
my name
rumpelstiltskin joke
it was a diet coke
i do think it's important number one
that i did just put my elbow on the
table and missed
leave that in uh so you guys know that
we actually
don't edit out the things we should edit
out just because when you guys complain
about us editing the show
second i'm glad that you witnessed an
actual manic break in real time
so that you can see that this this could
have been prevented
if emily just was on better help
this is not healthy or normal and
i'm actually more than ever this podcast
is sponsored by better help
and good for you listeners get 10 off
good for you employees also do so just
want to really
reiterate hammer this home for actually
your boss will cover it for free
but if you're a listener of good for you
ten percent
off their focus i know you don't listen
to the show uh
you get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com whitney which is written
on the screen
okay i see a stage direction in your
script oh
she has to know the song first
what song are you humming that's not
that song
you are not reading off the script now i
am annoying because this is funny
what are you saying over there aurora
borealis head
that's not how you would normally say
yet okay hang on
why is it when you write for someone and
you want them to act like themselves
they start acting like someone else
it's a great question huh
what are you singing over there aurora
borealis oh just this new ditty that
grace dropped about her student loan
debt
do you want to see it
my loan it's me
you've been calling me for oh so many
years for my
money to repay you
for everything you say
that i'm supposed to pay you but i ain't
got
much money my loan
can you hear me i
am so in debt and i need to know when i
will be free
from your clutches
and calls i'd forgotten how it felt
before your
interest buried me i need assistance
to pay off my college laws
was just trying to grow my mind
but now my
always seen you one more
my lungs so big i almost cried
now earnest
and is me to pay down
my college loan so now i can
buy fun things like check out my boat
on my boat
i bought a boat
[Music]
earnest offers low-rate student loan
refinancing and you can check your rate
risk-free in just two minutes
and you can get radically flexible
payments but grace probably couldn't
find anything to rhyme with that
okay i'm now about to read this entire
thing with one side of my hair curled
and the other knot so if you're not
watching on youtube
i feel sorry for you i stepped on that
line huh
ernest is offering our listeners 100 oh
good good thing she didn't try to rhyme
the next part
i agree david mamet over here ernest is
offering our listeners a hundred dollar
cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a 100
cash bonus refinance your student loans
at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply still
once again you're going to get a 100
cash bonus when you visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loan
not available in all states
terms and conditions apply visit
earnest.com whitney for more details
terms and conditions
apply earnest student loan refinancing
made by earnest operations llc nmls
pound one two oh four nine one seven
california financing law license number
605-4788
at 303 2nd street suite 401
n san francisco california 9194107 visit
earnest.com licenses for a full list of
licenses
god i think back because i was just
doing a lot of like these clubs like to
get ready for
theater to get you know to kick the rust
off and i think about like
do you think all those seemingly
thankless brutal morning show
like it was like a bar crawl right but
with we would go to like five radio
stations some of them are out of men's
own basement they're usually 30 minutes
outside of the city
totally some brutal like local nbc
station where all
you know what it feels like it was like
you know when you went to disneyland as
a kid and all the princesses looked like
princesses
and then as an adult you go and you see
them and all you see is the caked makeup
and like you're in like acne under
makeup and you're like oh god honey like
as an adult the princesses seem so
sad honey
disney see a disney princess in the
disney park as an adult
it's not the same way off with her head
she's
that foundation of your blood by the way
it's not foundation it's based
it's based on what you're talking about
i have no idea
is that krylon you see them like
sweating in their wig
and you're like oh my god they're so hot
that's all you think is like they're so
hot they're in these costumes
this is not like magical the way it was
when i was a kid because i now see this
as a human being
yeah i thought about that when i went to
i was telling emily when i went to the
wizarding world of harry potter for my
birthday
which is very fun um there's just people
dressed as witches and wizards like
putting just pouring trash into like a
bin they're just
they're not yeah they work there but i'm
just thinking like this man
we're supposed to be in this magical
world and you're still a janitor
that yes you're magical dude you're
playing the same music on loop all day
long there are crazy rules
disney princesses there's a great oh i
know there's a great youtube
wormhole to go into like deep diver on
that kind of stuff go into former dis
disney princesses from the park reveal
all the things they had to do
to look more like jasmine to look more
like um all of them and then they're not
allowed to eat or drink in public in
front of anyone
you have to answer your questions a
certain way yep they get that
you have or have to like get off the
floor you do some like
thing that a baseball player like what
are those called like a hand gesture
you're never allowed to talk as a disney
character no you can talk now but you
have to say certain lines
okay you have to like because there's
now video because people interact so
much with them now with tick tock and
stuff
they have to answer you as if they're in
their movie because you know now there's
like multiple maleficents and stuff
never break the spell oh you're always
in a character they don't want to pull
back the
curtain they want you to think they want
kids to believe all of that's real this
30 year old man is peter pan
but then but as a kid you do and i like
i remember because i went uh a friend of
mine is jenny goodwin who's been on the
podcast who is snow white
all right on that show yeah in real life
yeah what is it called
she's asleep right now once upon a time
and she was like telling me all the
crazy secrets about all of the like the
way they have to walk and the way they
have to move and stuff like that not my
secret anymore
we went because she can she gets like
she gets like rushed
to the front of the line of all the
lines and she'll do a big tour a night
we got to eat at the restaurant 33 yeah
secret restaurant
you know the secret is it's not that
good
it's like twenty thousand dollars a year
to be a member no way
yeah yeah yeah i'm like guys call your
dad and just get the apology you need we
don't need to keep going to disneyland
disney oh disney adulterer that's a
different breeder
what is like the gays
they're different too you know what they
all are is rich it costs four hundred
dollars
a lot of money you need to be in a jock
strap and a cut off t-shirt at disney
world oh
does that happen that's my head
i think every day
what's the most massive thing in disney
world the chipmunks i'm obsessed with
the cars
did you know goofy's a cow and not a dog
i didn't know that until recently
i know everyone is shocked i'm sorry i
apologize
for me he's a dog he's a cow with a pet
dog
why does he have two front teeth he's a
cow he's a cow
bitch i'm a cow bitch so i'm obsessed
with the fact that every night they
release a hundred cats
to eat all the rats in disneyland
disneyland i don't know
every every night they let out no you
let all the rats to kill the cats
yeah i'm like oh my gosh i had no idea
no disneyland the the machinations and
what like i'm obsessed with a quick
question yeah
how did they get the cat's back every
night yeah yeah
yeah the princess yeah she goes around
bella they ran out of the beast she
worked with the beast so she goes
because it's like on pavlov's dog like
they're trained to come back as a flute
they follow around the city they do the
security in disneyland
is so fascinating i'm obsessed with um
documentaries on vegas security how like
one out of every five people is a plain
clothes employee of the casino
and they're like constantly like you
know talking to the cameras and stuff
like that
and then the same as with uh disneyland
i think it's something like one out of
30 people as a plainclothes cop
every now and then if you just sit at
disneyland if you go without a child
which i don't recommend
uh they have lots of questions for you
it's like going to a dog park without a
dog everyone's like
and so uh so i was there with my friends
they were all into the stuff and i was
kind of holding back with the guide
like because i'm always like what's up
with this and what's this and what's
this made out of it how much does this
cost like i'm the asshole disneyland
who's like you know why do the ears cost
48 dollars where do they make them like
i'm always trying to figure out
like did i have questions that no one
gives a shit about magic i know
because i mean the disney ears there are
some that are like 200
like it's wild i'm like do parents buy
these like do you ever and i'm obsessed
with do you ever see fights do kids ever
get hurt like how come nobody hears
about any accidents
ever at disneyland they have a million
people covering it all up there's a jail
underneath
and he said that if you really sit
around in disneyland
past the jail part i'm with you yes give
me a second i'm come back to it it's
called building tension
uh and that's why i should do improv
if you just sit at disneyland and just
sit and watch and aren't chasing your
kids and freaking out about things
spilling and
you'll see every now and then just like
a plainclothes man walk up to another
man that doesn't have a kid and go
you're coming with me sir
like there are people that are
constantly just peeling off
guys that are there alone with no kids
you're like you're coming to me sir
we're going down and they go into the
thing and then they question them
so they're constantly just playing like
whack-a-mole with guys that are there
alone just regular disney employees are
now
no these are not they're police officers
these are police officers
but here's what i love about it is that
they have to dress like normal people i
love the idea of becoming a police
officer and you're like this badass
they're like oh you're playing close cop
now
you need tivos you need to
carry around a camera that goes some
salmon-colored shorts
like this guy thought he was gonna be
like a secret asian man
no i put this fanny pack on yeah i need
you to go to tommy bahama stats
why aren't you in uniform that you're
like this badass cop that could like
kill anyone with one finger
and now you just have to wear fucking
dad jeans everywhere
they also disney also invented their own
uh
paint color apparently that they paint
all the things like fire things they
don't want you to look at fire hard and
stuff
and the paint is like a special color
that makes your brain ignore it
fascinating oh my god i'm obsessed with
it so that way you only see what they
want you to see because they were
animators first do you like that we were
just making fun of disney adults now
we're like let me tell you everything
you know
disney adults here's everything i've
learned from my
20 years i'm just obsessed with shit
like that like you don't do are you ever
like in your
hotel room on tour near a like
theme park or like writing a script
writing a script
those days are over no like and then
you'll see in the morning at like six
flags or they
run the roller coasters before anyone's
allowed to be on them
you see them because they're like
testing them to see for any problem who
doesn't do that carnivals and that's why
i like i'm the danger
when you see someone like just a carny
smoking a cigarette
the ryan could break you could be
stabbed there's a lot of things that
could happen in a carnival dude
the pirate ship needs to come down
oh where that hangs over have you ever
it goes
and then hangs every time i'm on that
i'm like there's no way what about what
about
the ride the most carnivals that just
pinned you to a wall with no harness
it's going so fast
there's just a little tiny chain belt
against you and that and i'm just like
our parents just let us go in there they
didn't fucking know they were like oh
this is going to spin your child as fast
as possible i got killed on a carnival
ride as a kid
uh-huh yep
here's something benton says these
really insane things and then he won't
keep talking
and then i have to go tell us the story
now i'm the asshole
who's like dragging it out of you so
benjamin will say something insane where
i'll be like oh there's a groundhog
outside he'll go one time a groundhog
jumped into my go-kart and turn it back
in next week and i'll finish the story
yeah it's like when when news anchors go
like is your drinking water killing your
children
we'll let you know after the break you
know how it's like
big big theme parks they like have a
place where you test the ride to see if
you fit on the ride which is always in
front of the ride which is so fucking
rude
but it's like sit down see if you fit in
it then they put you in a certain order
so that way like
if all the gravity goes this way you're
not pressing the smaller people up
against the thing
uh-huh there's like a whole method to
that which is why they're sitting is
that like when you know when you're on a
plane and someone's like
ma'am can you move to uh rose back just
because of the plan you know
everyone can yeah i guess and i'm like
if a hundred and two hundred pounds
makes a difference we should
not we should stay great this is the
scale yeah um
but basically so at a carnival they're
just like get on the ride
and so i was like younger and then it
was my mom and then it was this they've
sat like this
very large man next to my mom but in the
wrong order so in the scrambler on the
scrambler that spins us
that's the thing with a bulb on the end
like a it has like it looks like a it's
like a
like a church pew and there's like three
of them and they they spin like this and
then the ride spins the opposite
direction
no and so because the way the gravity
went my head got pinned against the
middle bar and then all that weight and
i blacked out and my mom's like
screaming to stop the ride they can't
hear or do that
so when the ride stops i'm just like
pass out on the ride they have to call
the
ambulance and just pull me off the ride
you're like well that was the most fun
ever by the way have you ever been one
of the people
that i've made i did those swings
it's swings dude how do you feel safe on
that
i'm the kid you can take something you
can take food on them so you can eat a
corn dog and do it
yeah that's my favorite part i i i
because the promise when you're spinning
around
you can see the machinery of the ride
and you see it's just some weird like
there's like cardboard in there
and there's yeah also if you snapped
it's just gone
like it's just it's i'd rather do that
than the pirate ship
over like because that's so far up the
swings or at least
if you fell you'd probably you'd
probably make it you'd die
in what world would you probably
[Applause]
but i think you'll make it don't test me
on that theory though
what are you touring soon yes i am
touring can you take your lady with you
uh she's gonna be coming on a lot of it
most of it i think
we'll find out and then tom papa he's a
monster right
so me is that every morning he's very
still uh monday through thursday
yeah we're coming up on our two-year
anniversary did you have to commit to a
like a morning show like we have to
shoot this every day monday through
friday for the next year
will you commit a year at a time and
that's scary
it was scary at first just being someone
that i know didn't want to commit to jax
wasn't this scary and we know you hate
commitments
oh yeah i was scared because it was live
and i wasn't scared of the live aspect
but it was seven to nine so i had to get
up at 5 30 every morning
so and for a stand-up that's like
god-awful
so for the because it's live yeah for
the first year was tough only that
because i was prepping my my netflix
special
and i was having to you know do dates
every weekend and then the store every
you know a couple nights until really
late then i'd have to get up at 5 30 and
do the radio so i was
when my tour was supposed to start last
year supposed to start on march 14th
i was like a zombie i was like i don't
know how i'm gonna do this
and then everything got shut down and
then when everything got shut down we
started doing
uh taping a day ahead so now we don't
take that's exactly what i would say i
would say yeah
do it live on tuesday air it wednesday
yeah live on tuesday at five to air
wednesday
yeah and now i have so much more energy
and we have you know
a lot of fun does that i'm just so
curious does that come out a podcast
because i'm curious like who's still
listening to sirius if so are they also
listening to podcasts like
where did it where is it found it's
found on siriusxm a lot of people listen
to the app
so they're not listening in real time
per se yeah all right
i want to talk about your southern charm
okay we're going to play some games
let's do it take us to our fun games
shirt for a fun game
portions here we worked really hard on
this we're going to go through some
southern saying to kind of talk them out
see how we feel about it because it took
me a long time to realize that bless
your heart meant you're dumb you can
mean a lot that's a multi-purpose
like oh we feel bad for you yeah but
bless your heart i used to think it was
like oh
like bless your heart like you're so
numb we need to like pray for you
yeah yeah it's like no you didn't know
any better it means you're dumb
bless your heart's like a whole language
in itself yeah yeah that's right it also
means fuck you
in some areas yes what else does it mean
it's also i mean like you know poor
young that is that yeah
like it's it's almost like we said bitch
sometimes when
something bad has happened they're like
i'll bless your heart or if someone
did something dumb bless her when you're
gossiping bless her heart it's like
totally that's the meanest thing you can
say so we're gonna go through some of
these and just see if you've heard them
we'll talk about them see if we know
what they mean
emily can chime in on who she knows we
know the first one is
no sorry i just want we know uh
can't pour piss out of a boot i haven't
heard that one she ain't got to send
support piss out of a boot i hadn't
heard that one that's she doesn't have
common sense
yeah that's that's good can't poor piss
out
wouldn't think to pour the piss out i've
heard that i'm more nervous the long
tail cat in a room full of rocking
chairs
like it's such a long way to go did you
just say i'm nervous
she's lord on her wednesday she's more
nervous alone
in a room full of rugged chairs but
southerners like to
zuzia yeah everything's
when you ask a southerner for advice
they just say something that
that makes you figure it out like what
should i do and you're like well you got
to keep going where you go
and then you just have to figure out
what that means wherever
yeah and then you're like well i tried
that and it ruined my life i didn't tell
you do that now you heard what you heard
it's like a fortune cookie too where
it's like you take from it what you need
it's like a horoscope you know like when
you're like like for horoscopes whatever
we thought about this on the show so
much but when i go to i'm like yeah oh
yeah that's so true that's so true and i
was actually reading the wrong one and
it still applied to me because i
thought it was for me you know like it's
it's what you want it to be
these vague aphorisms are like what
about oh wow he squares a two dollar
bill
what i used to hear people say that
growing up because the two dollar bills
are very random
they're not usable and they're rare and
weird people want to keep them in their
basement they want to keep them in a
drawer
a lot though back in the day but they
would say it like not even
thinking it was how offensive it is
they were just like well that's queer
there's a two-letter bill and you're
like but it's also accidental
but like later in life you're like what
the hell what's that
but it's also something uh why aren't
you getting tanked full of sugar
yeah yeah when you got someone gay ain't
you gonna take full of sugar is that
your
little too much sugar in their tank oh
tank i think they said take containment
it's like y'all are wild when someone
says do you want to go this way
i reckon yeah i reckon i reckon
i reckon there was a hog down the road
that means i'm pretty sure i saw yeah
i reckon uh we'll just uh get out of
here and
go over yonder yeah go over under also
can you cut off the lights
she's mean as the day is long he's mean
as the day is long oh yeah
that's a good one here's the other thing
a lot of people in my family say
she's being ugly like not physically
uh well that don't amount to a hill of
beans i said that what does that mean
jellybeans ain't worth money it's not
worth yeah i love beans i have them in a
bag right now
yeah i don't amount to hillary beans
like you got nothing what about fair to
midland
i heard that one how you doing fair to
midland are you talking about my our
comedy career until five years ago
fair to midland that means someone's
like where's midland mediocre
yeah mediocre i'm okay to okay pretty
much the other one there's also will
i'll
be bobby well i'll be what like i can't
believe it
you know what else i like when i tell
you what is just
for as a wow i'll tell you what
there's also yeah but it's just an
expression that i would that it's
right you also you have your backyard
and your friend shirt
your backyard and your front yard front
yard what about the porch
f-r-u-n-c-h-e-r-d my mom says jumper
insisted
it's in texas it's pepper or
a pepper we said you want a coke okay
that could mean anything and
in louisiana they say uh a cold drink do
you have a cold drink what about sweet
tea did you have sweet tea oh that's all
you do
you ask for a tea it comes with sweets
if you get sweet tea anywhere
in the south it's just like you might
have to be like can you piss in that cup
but also if i could
import out of your boot if i ask for an
unsweetened tea
you're weird people like they're they
don't like can i get my
tea unsweetened yes
go bless your heart a doohickey
that's different we would all through
high school we'd be like don't but there
was also
duh duh and then doi and then hickey
we were such nerds you remember dahica i
know but i don't know
i know too big for your britches that's
i know what that means and also we and
we call shopping carts buggies yep we do
can you get them every time i met you
you're like but what's and also the
grocery store was always called the
kroger or the food lion
dixie win dixie
can i ask you a question yeah do you
ever get mad
yeah for sure i can't picture you being
like i'm gonna go fucking yelling
fucking get mad my mom you can be honest
you get in a fight
uh i feel like you're one of those
people that gets quiet
i definitely get quiet i repeat myself a
lot when i
am mad but i it takes a lot to get me
mad
i'm pretty even tempered when's that
time you cried uh
i i don't know watching documentaries
usually makes me cry
yeah yeah i got a couple more for you
okay okay sweating like a hooker in
church
we say whore in church
[Applause]
yep uh well she got her her nose stuck
up higher in the light pole
i hadn't heard that i don't even know it
means you think you're you're stuck up
you got your nose suck up higher noise
oh i've heard she's a brown nose well
that's been your that's different
okay okay um well
oh i'm just fat as a tick
no it's full as a tick i'm full of the
tickets
i say after you've eaten you mean yeah
i'm just fantastic
i'm a bad at the table some ticks aren't
uh it's amazing how
dumb la people are about ticks they're
everywhere and people see one like
we have to go to the eye of lyme disease
i'm like no ticks are you just
and people don't know how to kill them
out here you just take them off and then
you got to remove the head
and i'm like you have to remove the head
and then you just set them on fire yeah
or i just set myself on fire get them
all at once
people just don't know how to kill ticks
here's the very complicated thing you
have to do
take its head off sever it very cleanly
stake in the car and get a match
uh i hope you have a fire pit somewhere
and then you're going to want to set it
on fire
if you have gasoline great if not
what'll do
some kindling
ceremony i like to give my ticks a
viking funeral
have you ever heard have you ever heard
out here humping like a two-backed beast
out here humping like a two back beast i
don't think so
that means having sex well that means
they're getting their name dirty
dirty do you know how to kill a
rattlesnake uh with a shovel
first of all there's lots of ways you
say that there's one bite
they're not vampires
there's a lot
marriage
no because it's so i love hanging out
with people that are from the south
because there is such a
um obvious difference between people
that were raised
not like in terms of little things like
rattlesnakes like i've people come over
there from la and they're like
wouldn't even know what to do with a
rattlesnake i didn't deal with
rattlesnakes brandon schaub is one of
the biggest people on the planet right
there was a rattlesnake up here and he
said i don't know what to fucking do i'm
like dude
first of all they don't want to be near
you everyone thinks that rattlesnakes
are just sitting around waiting to bite
a human they want nothing to do with you
if if you're near them you're an idiot
you can't have your headphones on
because you would hear the rattle
right and then you have to get up and
yeah and cut their head off but most
people don't know that
i didn't really deal with rattlesnakes
growing up but i've
had to kill copperheads yeah copperheads
what's the they're in the water right
uh they're better swimmers both can swim
but they are how did you kill it
uh a shovel and then did you set it on
fire no
uh because i worked at the uh recreation
department in my hometown so i had to
uh do maintenance work you were like the
leslie knope
yeah have you ever ate rattlesnake it's
delicious
no i have not why but why why cook it
like i was in um
well because some people only had so
much to eat back in the day okay but
then why have you eaten it in the knot
in louisiana oh got it but also where
you're from no one from tennessee oh we
have more games more games
so this is can we have our june shines
emily you guys know that i'm obsessed
with toonshine this is what we're
drinking
june shine so it's like a healthy beer
and you'll take the shit of your life
tomorrow
or in 20 minutes and that's the
sponsorship
am i nervous okay so we're doing
think or drink bank or drink so these
are um these are a
a plethora okay of questions that i
didn't research
a lot but i did look them up and find
answers to them so hopefully they're
right if they're not
on infowars where do these answers
google things i was interested in and
seem like the google stuff so how do
when do we drink
or you get it wrong if we get it wrong
okay okay but june such a treat
on this on the mark norman episode
so let's start off this is going to be a
question for whitney
take your time don't rush what comedian
people aren't listening to this we
haven't been going to ours
you're talking over me okay what
comedian lived in spain for a year
before moving to la to become a personal
assistant and pursue comedy
is this someone where am i pulling from
your brain
um
not from spain but lived in spain for a
year
segura has a special in spanish or a
whole podcast in spanish
c do you think it was tom it was fortune
what did you do in spain uh i lived
there for a year after college
can you speak fluently uh um poco
no i lost a lot of it because it's been
a long time since i graduated college
name two comics who graduated summa cum
laude summa cum laude
uh greg geraldo went to an ive league
school i know that was that i believe
okay um greg gelda went to a fancy thing
and graduated high
uh i did but i don't think that's it it
was youtube that was the question
this is like this is like an annoying
trick this is like okay now go give it
give me another one
this is okay
how many legs does a house centipede
have
what
12 30. drink a little drink
by the way to give you the hardest one
so we just get fortune wasted i like
your stuff
when was the comedy store founded oh
month day here i don't know okay well it
used to be a place called
zeroes this is like i might get points
for my answer being interesting i only
have the one answer that i googled so if
it's not that you get no points
so uh it used to be a place called seros
which famously was like where the rat
pack hung out and the mafia in l.a
hung out so they they knocked a lot of
people off
in the basement so that's why they say
the comedy store is haunted because it
when it before it started because there
was comics there
but they killed a lot of people they
would basically the mafia would kill
people
uh put them in the chair to try to get
information out of them like in the
basement you know because by the way
sinatra would hang out there and marilyn
and all these people
i'm going to say you know a lot of stuff
but when was it 74
i'm guessing oh you're so close you
wanna try the the month or the day no
i'm gonna be guessing
april 7th 1970
three five one six
no one wants to hear that but we it's
not a fun game if we're just listening
to people guests
i think people like this thing
hey guys tune in this week you're going
to hear a lot of numbers fortune
yes name the largest continent in the
world asia
congratulations thank you that would
have tricked me because it's something
that's like i know i know this but the
fact that you're asking me makes me
doubt myself
that's why i hate these fucking what is
the title of the children of prince
williams
uh george no no that's mega man of them
the titles they're titled the fact that
i thought titles meant like their names
i don't you know that i don't fuck with
royalties i don't i don't care about
royalty
the prince and princess of cambridge i
don't find but
can i just say this what is the
fascination it's royalty
i think it's weird no i think it's cool
but why
these people were born into it they're
they didn't learn any of this i guess
the same reason watch princess movies
and royalty movies
drink oh yeah um
fortune how tall is jennifer aniston
your buddy
your best friend she would be five
six she's great i would have said that
i would have said that that was close do
you get asked to officiate a lot of
weddings
uh i mean you know people will say like
oh you
we'd love for you to marry us but i i
mean it's never an official
so i can't you should charge them are
you on cameo
uh yeah and how do you feel about it i i
don't mind it i like it here's what i
will say
because but because the people that get
i don't ever
promote it that i'm on there because i
you know
whatever uh but the people are like the
only person i wouldn't make fun of if
you promote it but people
want video they i get emails all day
every day for videos and i just
can't get to all the videos so i did it
to just be able to
because people wanted them so much i
know that sounds so stupid they do it
it's really special people love the
videos and so have you ever missed a
cameo and it like ruins your streak
no i mean uh yeah i mean i'll do them
when i can you know
oh well you know you have three days and
if you miss them it like shows on your
page it's like
missed like it's not reliable it's
almost like we've had 14 days since an
accident if you missed it it's like zero
and i'm like
but here's what's so funny like so i was
when i was in north carolina a friend of
mine
was like oh we love um justin willman
the magician
and he's i've known him for 20 years
back when he was a college magician
he would do like college is and he was
called just incredible
oh yeah and i i've known him for so long
and i was like it's so weird when
someone you've known for so long
is now like it's just it's just weird
and like the idea that they're like yeah
we got a cameo from just a moment i was
like let me fucking see that shit
because he's my friend
right and then i looked at it and he's
like
hey cindy and mike like
everyone's doing their hustle i mean
like i heard you were having a birthday
and i
heard you're allergic to vanilla so your
cake is probably gonna have to be
your favorite red velvet see i have such
a fear of you seeing one of mine that i
set up a backdrop and i take what i'm
gonna say to the wall so i look like
this i can look directly at it if i see
and go why the fuck are you reading it
i don't even do that on your private
stuff but i'm picking shoes like their
people will be like will you
you know can we pay you this to promote
the same i'm like no i don't i don't
like i don't use that product so it's
like i like
it because uh people that are fans
genuinely really enjoy it that's right
but then i
i took a video of his video and texted
it to him and he was like
dude that's every comedian's nightmare
is for another comedian to see the
private cameo they sent yeah
it's like that that's so off like that's
so fucked up that's so like not playing
playing fair
right because we're being so corny we're
like hey lindsay
good to see ya there's some really
cringy
celebrity cameos that have been leaked
online and it's it's tricky to watch
so our next question whitney
how many bones are in the human body i
don't know that's a great question it's
going to be either egregiously
surprisingly
it's like when they say like how many
bones are in your hand and someone's
like fifteen thousand and you're like
uh thirty five hundred two hundred and
six
yeah i had no idea drink up sasquatch
aurora burley
[Laughter]
according to hillary duff if the light
is off then
blank if a lot if the light is off
oh you're getting molested finish it if
the light is off
uh there's some love making
that's about to happen the correct
answer is if the light is off
then it isn't on that's a famous lyric
in the hillary duff song so yesterday
well drink up it is a
fair honestly it's by the way it's like
one of those southern sayings
if the light's off then it's dark yeah
like
yeah if it's not if it's off it's not on
yeah if yeah if the light's on
it's not off so figure your shit out
again fair enough whitney
sir who is this southern girl with
levi's on an open heart who wishes they
could save the world like they were
supergirl
deanna carter jessica simpson everyone
jessica simpson did you see that there
was a uh did you drink it oh
no thank you happily oh what a
punishment oh
bummer i can drink my favorite drink at
fucking 6 p.m
uh let me ask uh jessica simpson did you
see there was like an article
that people were going like we owe
jessica simpson an apology because we
used to use women's trauma as our own
entertainment like there's this trend
happening now where we like oh lindsay
lohan an apology and
paris hilton all these people like i i
never had thought about jessica simpson
but i guess
like we hyper-sexualized her it's like
did we or did i mean people made fun of
her a lot
so i but if you're that famous but
remember whenever you're in five movies
a year you're gonna be made fun of
remember when she asked if buffalo wings
were made of buffalo
and everybody made fun of her and then
she got that pizza hut deal for
all that money yeah so jokes on them
like
and also remember it's like when um demi
lovato someone said what's your favorite
what was it what's your favorite dish
like what's your favorite food and she
said
mugs are my favorite dish that's like a
miscongeniality i was like what's your
favorite date and she's like april was
like
exactly like i was like she's not wrong
but why are we shaming her from not
having
thought of right food it's it is called
the same thing this is where your brain
your brain goes to something yeah she
just was like mugs
like she didn't go like why would she
was not wrong yeah
they could be both i'd rather hear the
answer to that question
someone's favorite food
[Laughter]
fortune what's the national dish of
america oh
french fries mac and cheese hamburger
okay
i think it's a drink i think it's mac
and cheese also
um just so uh you guys understand where
i get my ancestral genius around
business
my grandfather had the opportunity and
to invest in mcdonald's and said
no thank you that's a stupid business
idea oh
man it's like when i didn't invest in
uber i was like that's dumb who's gonna
get in cars with strangers
yeah my grandmother could have bought
stock in coca-cola
well at the time it was cocaine was in
it even better
i know what a knitting i hooked up with
a guy
and woke up the next morning and i was
talking to his roommate and his roommate
was like i'm writing a script and i was
like tell me about it and he's like it's
a musical about l.a and i go okay yeah
good luck that's going to be great it
was la la la la la
yeah you're like who wants to hear about
l.a
whitney in texas it is illegal to swear
in front of what
in texas it's illegal to swear in front
of
my aunt frankie of course a corpse
yeah there's a lot of like weird laws
about that
oh shit you're dead
now you're going to jail i have this
theory that it backfires because when
people are like
you know oh it's illegal in baton rouge
to have sex with a mule on sundays you
know
like and you're like oh that was like a
crazy law and you think like it was
obviously to me someone that's like a
weird like
like my favorite addiction and all those
weirdos that are in like relationship
with cars and baby powder and stuff
where if you hear that now to talk about
it rehash it now is probably unhealthy
because someone's going to go
well this is what happens in like
12-step rooms when
drug addicts like hear about new things
they've never heard of someone's like i
gave up my
baby for heroin like i gotta try fucking
heroin if this guy's giving up his baby
so like someone will go i hate my baby i
would i wasn't planning on fucking a
mule on sundays but if they had to make
a law to stop it
must be pretty good
a lot of people were doing it to a point
to where it was so disruptive
that they had to make a law somehow or
they just saw one person duty and got
really worried
the one person that did it did it so
crazily
based on the one time it happened
in florida only on sundays it is illegal
for a single woman to do what
in florida only on sundays it's illegal
for a woman
to a single woman they wanted to talk
chat chat chat skydive is the answer
skydive have you ever skydiving
i literally i will not i will never i
literally think
i i people are always like doing
standout must be the scariest thing ever
and i don't know how to do it anytime
someone skydives i
i truly get to point when someone's like
should should just kind of i'm like we
shouldn't be friends yeah we
talk about this we shouldn't be friends
like that's
how crazy that's how crazy i think i'll
never jump out of a plane unless i'm
pushed
it's not for me i don't want to i just
can
i could never understand a situation
where i would look at a plane and be
like i would love to jump out of that
people
and like kareem to the earth with the
umbrella that may or may not open
with some fucking guy who like you know
smokes on four try what kind of person
that diving don't
have an instructor like that person i
don't want to wear a person like a
backpack
to see and they're like the view is
beautiful you're like
my eyes are closed it's almost like the
graviton i'm just gonna puke and it'll
go back in my face
puke skydiving i'm sure pull up the
video
sure it's like all these billionaires
going to space people like you want to
do that i'm like no
have you why would i want to do that and
they're like these people are i'm like
bye yeah we're going to go to space i
can hardly get to the comedy store for
myself
the real question is why do so many rich
people want to go to space
they're bored i have one more question
whitney troy bolton's dad in high school
musical
i is the brother-in-law of which famous
actress in real life
this is literally benton on a first date
by the way you
just with your nerd knowledge about
buffy
fucking comment no one knows the answer
to this sorry i know so much about the
business you're in i disassociated from
what you just said i don't know what
anything you don't even know anything
about high school musical
you know but benton you know me more
than anyone
you know i mean you're never gonna be
like the brain dude
tell me about how if i was born in 1905
do i carry the trauma over to my mother
like that's not what i'm here for it's
blake lovely it's the answer
you know i would never know the answer
to any of these
well fortune yeah what year did the
stonewall riots take place
oh man why why this question
what kind of sick suggesting what does
this have to do with anything
64. 69.
you're evil like yeah like imagine
benjamin coming up with these questions
is psychotic let's give whitney wands
only about this will be good for you is
the clitoris
bigger or smaller than your thumb aren't
all of them truly
i don't know if you don't know
portuguese you definitely don't know
it depends on how big your thumb is
swollen
it's bigger always because the clitoris
extends well below the surface and has
five inch tubes that go down the wall of
your vagina whoa
whoa that's a lot why are you ruining
their marriage
why are you ruining their sex life and
then i have what do we drink
we gotta drink to that i got one more
for you whitney yeah
when does i got one more thing i just
want to embarrass you on
when does hannah you know that i don't
know the answer i already know the
answer
i don't know i already know the answer
is this montana question
first meet colin in the movie maid of
honor oh shit
you are a fucking you're a scoundrel
benjen ray
uh this is a movie i was in when did
they met when they were kids
well the question was where not when
but you got it right museum museum
everyone knows this
is scotland they met in scotland
scotland wait was that the the the
the husband the guy the redhead guy
watched somebody that's just a question
i have one more question whitney oh
please who claimed they could drive away
the devil with a fart
you're an evil person you went you went
to a nice school you should know that i
don't like fart
humor it's not humor this is a this is
the real
thing that a a very important person in
history said benjamin franklin
the german priest martin luther king you
knew i wasn't you know the answer to
this
i know but isn't that more but you just
sit here and go this will be like a
really fun podcast
i'm gonna just well i think if i asked
you questions you knew it would be like
two months where did you where did you
go on quora like where did you even find
all this stuff
i just was typing in i was just typing
questions i thought were crazy and see
what came up
we now interrupt your regularly
scheduled hilarity to talk about
something as refreshing and cool
as fortune feedster course pure
coors pure is simple beer with organic
barley organic hops and
water it's all organic and has zero
sugar so you can enjoy it without
feeling guilty
you know what else i enjoy without
feeling guilty hmm asmr
let's read the rest of this info as asm
artists okay
92 calories and zero sugar
of course pure is the perfect beer for a
balanced
lifestyle
don't you love coors pure it is so
incredibly
delicious let's all do it a swallow
a swallow i sip in a swallow
like it because it's organic like myself
and also um it hops around also like
myself
and it has made of water and i'm also
mostly made of water
so really this beer reminds me a lot of
myself and that's why i like it why do
you like it
i like it because you know i'm a slut
for gorgeous packaging that doesn't make
you look like an idiot when you bring it
in your purse
so i love that it's so clean and classy
and there's mounts on the front because
you know i love now the virginia
mountains and that's what it reminds me
of
and then it reminds me of my childhood
and then i get traumatized
but then i drink it and i feel better so
when you want to enjoy a beer without
without the guilt reach for course pure
it's
you're not trying to scare children okay
why don't you take this part okay
oh my god when emily drinks she gets so
hilarious
if there's a line anywhere she's gonna
be pissed
when you want to enjoy a beer without
the guilt reach for coarse pure it's
organic
but chill about it go to coarsepure.com
to see where you can find course pure
mandatory disclaimer celebrate
responsibly
course brewing company albany georgia
we thought we'd do something a little
bit different this ad because there's
lots of serious copy to read
so whilst you are reading it quillest
quillest you are reading about new
cake condoms benton and i
are gonna have a little contest and
those that screwing that's going on in
the background if you hear it it is on
purpose
to subtly suggest screwing it's like
where it's a subconscious sexual
vibe it's turning me on and it's totally
on purpose 100
so uh we're gonna take it back to middle
school and we're gonna put some of these
cake condoms on our
dicks and they're cucumbers
they're those are cucumbers so so you
are using these incredible uh
cake sexual wellness and pleasure
products
uh different sizes a cucumber that looks
like you got
on sale at the airport snug
they fit up to 6.8 inch long weenies oh
and the packaging is unbelievable
standard fit which is up to seven inch
weenies
okay and then you have the large condoms
which are up to 8.1 inch long weenies
and also they have various uh tush play
uh lubes and other kinds of layers yeah
they got toys
they're not here because i've used them
personally don't mean to brag
but i don't lube up easily from the side
of my lover
so i use cake lube now
for you to start your competition which
is what
lube these guys up mm-hmm whoever can
get a cake
condom snuggly and safely fit on their
cucumber by the time you're reading
is the winner responsible though and we
do want you to lube your
dick up after you put the condom on not
before right
i between both of you who do you think
has less
experience or more experience with dicks
at all
this is going to be a very interesting
thing to watch first of all
i'm just saying let's make sure the
camera angle's not on me and it's fully
on them
as i explain that there is a new better
version
of ky jelly or trojan maybe
things with your partner or things with
your palm
i've gotten a little routine rutinized
slow down i can't tell
you can't do this you guys have maybe
your three-way
fantasies are starting to feel a little
menage a
blah if this sounds like you you need to
try out cake
risk-free cake makes premium lubricants
sex toys
condoms and more everything you need to
have the most fun
you've ever had in the bedroom or on a
chess lounge
or in the backseat of a convertible or
on a roller coaster you know where i'm
going with this
if toys are your favorite accessory they
have a non-drip
lubricant called toy wonder that is
especially designed to stay in place
so it doesn't run off your toys and ruin
your sheets cake is on a mission to make
sure everything they do
they do for you and that it is 100
satisfying the sentence was all actually
cake is on a mission to make sure
everything they do for you
or to you is 100
satisfying if there's ever anything
about their products that doesn't turn
you on cake will do the right thing and
they will give you
your money back no need to return the
product
they don't ask questions so
what are you waiting for make sex more
fun and easy
with cake just visit hellocake.com
and enter good for you at checkout for
25 off then click
order and sit back while more enjoyable
less shameful more
fun sex makes its way right to your door
that's hellocake.com
and use your promo code good for 25
off i can spend my life
in this sweet surrender
because every moment's been with are you
ready this is a great segue
i suffered from low sex drive for a full
year
whether or not benton singing that song
to you could possibly be the cause of it
i don't know
having a low sex drive is very
distressing it's how you connect with
your partner it's how you
normally de-stress having sex is
relaxing when you lose your sex drive
i started to panic i was like word i was
like am i broken
is something wrong with me were you not
trying hard enough
i did everything mountain i watched
legends of the fall in slow motion the
julia armond scene where she
cheats that used to do it every time no
longer i listen to
baby face i watch nigella lawson
cook bacon with coca-cola still
nothing the things that normally would
have turned me on didn't that is a
problem that is a problem addie
or flib anserin god it makes me feel
smart to say the
like pharmaceutical name flib answerin
is the fda approved
little pink pill for certain
pre-menopausal women
bothered by low sex drive visit
a-d-d-y-i
dot com slash whitney and complete your
online consultation to see if addie
is right for you adi is for
pre-menopausal women
with acquired generalized hypoactive
or low sexual desire disorder which is
also called
hsdd who have not had problems with low
sexual desire in the past
who have low sexual desire no matter
what type of sexual activity
the situation or the sexual partner
the low sexual desire is troubling to
them and is not
due to a medical or mental health
problem
problems in the relationship or medicine
or
other drug use a-d-d-y-i
is not for use in men or to enhance
sexual performance your risk of severe
low blood pressure and fainting is
increased if you drink
one to two standard alcoholic drinks
close
in the time to your addy dose wait at
least two hours
after drinking before taking addie at
bedtime your risk of severe
low blood pressure and fainting is also
increased if you take a certain
prescription
over the counter or herbal medications
or have liver problems
low blood pressure and fainting can
happen when you take
addie even if you don't drink alcohol or
take other medicines
sleepiness sometimes serious can occur
common side effects include
dizziness nausea tiredness difficulty
falling asleep or staying asleep
and dry mouth see full pi including
boxed warning at addy
a d d y i dot com slash
p i or call 844
pink pill that's 844
pink pill visit addie dot com slash
whitney
that's a d a-d-d-y-i dot-com
slash whitney do you want to open some
presents sure
see this is why you should put more
effort into your podcast because it pays
off
i get presents okay but with the audio
we can't oh
sorry okay don't be loud with the gift i
gave you like
we just made so this is just put tons of
wrapping paper in here
this is how what are your thoughts on
gender reveal bombs
no they're not great no
no to gender reveals you're like setting
forests on fire people are dying from
them
yeah the my baby's gender is uh i'm in
jail
for setting up this is what that is for
would you do a gender it's just a color
fun bomb would you do when you guys have
kids are you going to
find out the gender first i don't think
we're going to have
i don't think we're going to have kids
just want to make sure jack's hears that
in the corner
it's on right now she's on board of not
having kids this is a lubricant yes
thank you it's a sponsor called toy
wonder called cake they sent it to us a
non-drip lubricant for toy plate look
how
advanced sex toys are becoming and sex
also it's shame free i don't feel so bad
about being on cameo now
i have a new thing that's the most
embarrassing thing on the internet
oh let's see non-drip water base look at
the packaging
sparkle syrup okay this is something
shaken up
you need to have a bigger reaction to
this i'm laughing because my mom gave me
sparkle syrup for christmas
[Laughter]
oh
you thought that you were keeping them
in business yes in spokane i was like
i'm gonna you know what no one's ever
heard of you i'm gonna totally blow you
up by giving him
i guess so this is a thing a lot of
people have it's maple syrup that's full
of
glitter i don't know if a lot of people
have it but you and my mommy just might
be on the same page
so you had to fake enthusiasm
[Laughter]
i don't think you're supposed to eat it
that's the most fucked up part about it
like this is beautiful don't touch it
you're not really this is no i don't
know
i mean that's the thing like can you
taste the glitter what is it it's uh the
ingredients uh
uh maple syrup it's edible glitter
pearlescent pigment
is what's in it but look you shake it up
away i'm to just be making a lot of
pancakes with this one
how cute thank you if you if this
happened the first time she would have
been very excited
this is done i didn't know what is this
i don't know why i'm giving all this
man eater a sour orange flavored
bodybuilder
on it yeah i did because i don't have a
lot of help around here
it's i got this um do you ever like go
to stop like dude
they look like penises yeah they're it's
a shark with man
with pieces of a human inside that you
eat oh don't open it's on basically no i
can't either is this bad pr for sharks
is this what happens when you don't have
kids you start buying kids toys for your
adult friends i think so i just want to
let you know this is how whitney buys
everyone's gifts
i just like i buy things that i think
are cool and i keep them in a big closet
and then when people come on i just like
throw them in and then as soon as i give
them i feel
regrets i've got to get them back in
their shark case i'm such a weirdo i'm
like here's space ice cream like i just
like to give gifts that make me let's
see what that is
they're titties this is i remember i
ordered this the titty it's a
remember i ordered this it's an apron
with titties on it
you're like a pancake sweet by the way
oh this
is the pleasure serum the women's
pleasures i thought we should talk about
it it's used i used it
oh for that for that just for the
job well that's it stop don't show that
what did isn't this funny there's dried
stuff around why do i have a sense of
humor of like a divorced aunt
that's a cool apron from like pensacola
that's pretty a funny apron though i
don't know i'm like bitch get in the
kitchen
but do you have another bag too yeah
it's and now i'm embarrassed i don't
want to give up
no i want to see it i want to look at it
first wait
this is the this is the most fun can i
read you the back of this
one i'll give you the best of this
women's pleasure
i want to see what else is not bad no
they're not going to be no
i'm going to save them for some money i
appreciate them don't be a brand
whitney but that's a big deal and i want
to read a couple chapters
oh the young wife's advice book
this is from what the 50s from my cousin
morgan
i'm obsessed with vintage books
that's inviting you to turn i don't know
oh my god
i love this prank there's a thing on
pregnancy administration nursing
i collect women's advice books
they're always like to be a good
secretary make sure to always take your
wedding ring off before you go in
the building it's like advice for women
from 50 years ago
like just read anything from random i
wanted to know what confinement meant
um it means your queer is a two dollar
bill
let's see just read any sentence uh
pregnancy heartburn
during pregnancy many women suffer from
what is known as heartburn
this disagreeable affection
is caused by the accumulation of an acid
secretion
i need advice exercise offensive
let's see there was one that said um
like after you have your child you might
feel like a burning desire to leave your
husband
you have to just work through it like
it's like this whole thing that was like
don't leave
just stay like it's like
the confinement part has uh the bedroom
the room in which the woman intends
being confined should not be chosen
without previous thought
as regards as regards size i feel like
they left out some words
the room should be ample and should
women couldn't read yeah
that bad part the bed the best kind of
bed to have in the
lying in room is one made of iron
it should not stand above three feet
from the ground and the mattress should
be of horse hair
is this for women to just lie on a
mattress in a room the fewer curtains
there are about the bed
the better so this is your spell large
sheet of macintosh
or other waterproof material should be
placed above the mattress to protect it
like this is to give birth at home
oh is it is it why is it called
confinement because you because
is that the word for birthing yeah well
i know i think it's just like if a woman
started having like labor pains really
just
i think this is all about having
children
it's the young wives handbook oh you're
a young wife
well let's call morg morg
a lot of it is so funny because it's all
just like so weirdly gasps oh it is a
lot about
nursing bringing up the baby a lot of it
is like hit them in the face if they're
bad
i really want to see the other presents
please no
please i like it that's i'm learning so
much about you because it's like there
are two kinds of people in the world
ones that like black lecturers okay
there's two kinds of people in the world
one that can speak and when they can't
take two everyone's like do you wear a
biz line i'm like no no excuses just my
stutter two kinds of people in the world
ones that like black group
there are two kind of people in the
world one is it like black licorice is
in this june show
the ones that like red licorice and then
there are people
that can tolerate surprises and that
can't
you're one of those people that if
someone goes i was going to tell you i
was going to tell you something you know
what i'm not going to tell you you're
one of the people that has to do no
i don't know what i wasn't going to talk
about but that's not the bad person
the bad person is the one that goes i'm
going to taste it no i'm not but there
are times when i'm like
oh i'm not gonna do like you are not
gonna be able to handle me not showing
you can i just see
i would be able to handle i'd be like
all right i guess i'm like but you're
like
there's i'm fascinated by that and
that's probably such a great community
because you're like i have to fucking i
wanna know
i want to know what's in it it was more
of the vella pleasure serum
uh in a box and then there was one other
thing maybe coming come easy
i'm just well i mean this is funny
i mean this is a used pleasure serum
but i don't know why you think that
you're like
i don't know why you're so shocked that
you're like why is she not more into
this
what what's wrong with fortune that
she's not grateful
i mean the freaking maple syrup was a
huge hit
i know she just opened a uh a
very used not slightly a berries
women's pleasure serum that's caked on
the top
because it's it's crusty and
in just ah it's like what what am i
touching you're really blew by
the sex toys
the idea of whitney being like i'm
excited about the toy wonder actually
by the way you're very you know what i'm
gonna tell you something i've known you
for 15 years you're a jaded diva you've
got so many gift bags at this point
you have so much free shit that now
you're just like oh my goodness
listen whitney i'm pumped for 15 years
ago fortune would have appreciated this
toy wonder you're dead you've changed
because your fame has changed
it's free from gluten and that's what
i'm excited about
i don't ever put gluten in my food no
sulfates or fragrances
or shells all right well this could also
i love lube if you really try maple
syrup well your mom and i
at least i learned that your mom and i
have something in common we don't but
she's a nice like but i
appreciate all your gifts they're
just interesting i mean mostly this
one's what i'm
concerned about i wasn't a little
concerned
look did you see this so funny nothing
has been funnier than this
at least look at this part okay so okay
oh i'm sure i'm sure it was great when
you you used it i didn't
use it i have given up on making sex
pleasurable
ages ago i don't try anymore now i'm
just eating lots of pancakes with
sparkly syrup do you ever feel like
though you never really got to have your
childhood in 10 years
or 20s and like now we get to do it i'm
like sparkles like i'm hours
i put like stickers on my computer i'm
like totally back to being like
i'm like benjamin button emotion there's
nothing wrong with that you're having
fun
you go to some some talk shows they give
you like
like whiskey and nice shampoo i don't
want that i'm like
let's make smiley face pancakes
[Laughter]
i love it well i like i was only
laughing
because of the fact that my like what
are the odds that my mom had just given
given me that and i wish we had like
ring camera footage of me
i worked so hard to put this down when
you guys left the other night and i
definitely have she sent us a photo that
says
make sure she opens these on camera as
if she wasn't gonna well i will oh
i would open the restaurant i think i
had a little like
weed or something i don't know i think
yeah because i was like you're like yeah
that now would make because i was like
okay nissan trope and this and this will
be hilarious like i thought this was
going to be some real gems in there that
i'm missing out on i was like dude this
is going to be
epic you you can just re-gift them next
week no but the best is when you
picked up the the anal room and just
went
oh ain't a loom
because there's all these new fancy if i
was like if i had known it was
movement where like sex foreign are made
like by women for women
yeah and they're all like so cute and
fancy and like you know like it's just
funny to me like
what women are doing now that they get
to make them because before like there
was glitter in those jelly cocks back in
that you know what i mean like it's
funny how they were actually more girly
before remember the jelly cotton there
was glitter in them
remember the ones that were like tie-dye
and like see-through pink with glitter
and
jam-packed is this for a child is this a
giant jelly cock
for a toddler like why the pink and the
glitter so now it's weird to me because
when women are making them they're oddly
like slightly more masculine
yeah they're like simple they're like
yeah that's interesting
listen i will wear this booby apron for
sure when you make your pancakes
yeah come on now you want a funny jaunty
instagram post with those
it would people would go buck wire i
love a jaunty
instagram post and in between you can
have a little shark trait
yeah and then you can eat your your
man-eater you can eat your little
candies yeah i like it a lot
you know what i really do honestly
spencer's
gifts went out of business when i when i
stopped i mean i am a spencer's gift
like
i'm a gag gif person and they are never
funny
they always bomb gag gifts always
bomb there's a guy david david goodman
who used to run king of the hill one
time he said
the way that he runs shows the first
thing he says in the writers room
is nobody ever get me a gag gift uh-huh
it's too much pres it's not funny
let's meet all my friends nobody
everybody everybody starts with this
because if you get a gag gift you're
like
hot like like yeah we'll be
give me a serious gift and i'll be funny
about it don't give me a gag gift
because then you have to be like
here's my my fucking condom hat
well i like that you've committed to it
the only good thing about a gag gift is
that i immediately know that i never
have to buy that person to give back
that's true yeah yeah anyway
well i appreciate it we'll get it round
two we'll get around
when you come round two there you go
next time you come on the podcast this
gift bag is gonna be
well what if i get you a gift card or
hermes okay i'll take it
[Applause]
like underwear and you're like could you
just like got me and watch
like it's all like funny stuff or like i
feel like i'd rather just have a gift
card
i appreciate the thought that went into
it thank you i love you
i love you i'm very this is like long
overdue but i
i i want with comedians i want to wait
until i figured it out
especially people with podcasts i get
embarrassed because i'm like i'm gonna
wait until i'm like better at podcasting
to ask
that person to come on well i'm you're
great at it and i'm
glad you asked me has anyone done like a
chelsea lately reunion podcast
uh i don't think so i did like a virtual
show where a lot of them popped up on
the zoom yeah but no one's done a
podcast you should
do one think about it
yeah i'm working on my my gifts
i'm building my gifting brand i've gotta
call spencers
um i end these awkwardly i love you guys
uh fortune
tell me all about the tour tell everyone
where to go so i don't fuck it up uh
go to fortunefiester.com i'm going on
tour all over the country
uh it's called too sweet too salty all
new material
and i'm excited it's my excuse me it's
my first
syrup it's my first theater tour to coat
your throat
it's my first theater tour come on
that's a big deal so i'm very excited
and check out
uh if you haven't seen my stand up i
have a netflix special called sweet and
salty that's on
and then that's people and the next
special will be called sparkle serve
sparkles
people love that special i appreciate it
it's so good
your podcast and um uh i do a podcast
sincerely fortune my wife jax is on
there
unfortunately i've been asked to be on
sincerely fortunately you gotta do it
sometimes
at least it unfortunately should do a
lot sincerely 4chan and it's just you
reading 4chan
like like q anon comments oh god
it would be huge
i've been right before i've been right
before well me and my sparkle syrup are
going to get out of here
i'm so pissed off that that wasn't a hit
it was a hit to me
ben did sign off for us um be sure to
like and subscribe
go buy our new merch you can text us
818-239-7527 you can leave us a
voicemail at 818-538-9940
you can email us your videos and
questions at good for you fans at
gmo.com
make sure to like subscribe hit the
notification bell and don't ride
motherfucking elephant also uh
to buy this uh sparkle syrup that we're
all talking about
you'll have to contact me directly
because i bought all of them
[Music]
four four four six